[Musique]
alors
viens comme tu es
comme tu veux
être comme un ami
comme un ami comme un vieil
ennemi prends ton temps
dépêche-toi le choix t'appartient
ne sois pas en retard repose-toi
comme un ami comme un
vieux souvenir
mémoire
[Musique]
comme je veux que tu sois
comme un ami comme
mémoire
[Musique]
un spectacle si tu es un garçon ou une fille
hé bébé tes cheveux
vont bien hé bébé allons-y la nuit
tu m'aimes bien et j'aime tout  tu aimes
danser et tu es si belle
ton amour attend de jouer fort
tu en veux plus tu le veux mieux
mets ton foutu dis que je me trompe
tu prends mince tu les mets tous
reverb mais sur ta robe
[Musique]
reverbs
elle n'est pas
sure et j'aime ça
moi
je suis toujours là
sois
tout seul comme une pierre qui roule
euh
personne n'a jamais pensé qu'il devait vivre dans
la rue
mais maintenant tu vas devoir avoir
[Musique]
tu réalises qu'il
n'envoie personne
comme tu le vois dans le fond de ses
yeux  et demande-lui si tu
veux faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant je veux être ton chien
maintenant je suis prêt à fermer les yeux
[Musique]
et maintenant je suis prêt à fermer mon
esprit
[Musique] [Musique]
[Musique  ]
inclinez-vous
[Musique]
la lune
si vous voyez ou
pleurez
[Musique]
laissez tomber
je suis désolé
[Musique]
bébé
je sais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
blue
you